Це одна з улюблених світлин фотографа Макса Левіна,
зроблена ним в окупованому Іловайську 5 років тому.
На ньому військовий з позивним "Орест" спостерігає, як їсть дівчинка.
В місті вже були проблеми з харчами, тож бійці нерідко ділилися сухпайками з місцевими.
Це фото є частиною документального проекту AFTERILOVAISK,
в якому фотограф збирає фото та відеоспогади свідків та бійців, які вижили в "Іловайському котлі".
Це важливо пережити. Багато моїх друзів просто кажуть: "Я не хочу це дивитися, це дуже боляче".
"Я не можу це слухати: мені дуже болить".
Але поки ми цього не прослухаємо, не проживемо очима цих хлопців - ми не відпустимо цю історію.
Це не буде уроком для нас.
Макс не намагається показати, хто винний в Іловайському котлі.
Через доволі різні спогади військових висновки може зробити сам глядач.
Втім, фотограф, що чудом вирвався з оточення, хотів би нарешті почути всю правду про ті події.
Я розумію, що багато генералів просто не вміли воювати, не було досвіду,
але якщо накази були справді злочинними, тому що...
21-23 числа один з наших друзів-військових сказав, що йому високопоставлені друзі-чиновники,
підполковники з Києва дзвонили і казали: Макс, виходь звідти,
тому що там буде все погано.
Інформація про оточення була ще до заходу російських військових 23 числа, через кордон.
Військова агресія Збройних сил Російської Федерації є єдиним фактором,
що спричинив Іловайську трагедію у серпні 2014 року.
Про це ще два роки тому відзвітувала Військова прокуратура України.
Відтоді справа не зрушила з місця, а її хід засекречений.
Деякі родичі загиблих звинувачують українську владу в тому,
що розслідування не є незалежним і затягується.
Такої думки зокрема Галина Пугачова, мама добровольця батальйону "Донбас" Павла Пугачова.
Він безвісти зник під час виходу через так званий "зелений коридор".
Я вимагаю, щоб були покарані дійсно наші командувачі,
ті, хто давав команди хлопцям, не дивлячись на те, що
було видно, що Іловайськ в оточенні. Чому не відвели хлопців, чому не прийшла допомога?
Перші призначення Володимира Зеленського Галина сприйняла неоднозначно.
Адже керівником Генштабу став Руслан Хомчак, який в 2014 році керував Іловайською операцією.
Втім, все одно має надії, що зі зміною влади розслідування "Іловайська" зрушить з місця.
З Порошенком за 5 років не вдалося знайти жодного контакту.
Але будемо сподіватись, що зараз якісь зміни будуть і будуть на краще.
Для мене дуже важливо, щоб знали і чули про мого сина… Ось він.
Йому в цьому році 27 рочків.
На нову Верховну Раду розраховує й адвокатка Аліна Павлюк,
яка веде в Європейському суді з прав людини
справи загиблих в Іловайську добровольців батальйону "Донбас".
Зокрема українські депутати мають запустити реформи правоохоронних органів
та створити окрему структуру, яка б займалася міжнародними злочинами.
Такими є події на Сході України та в Криму.
Донедавна розслідуванням Іловайської трагедії
займалось окреме управління Військової прокуратури України,
нині - Державне бюро розслідувань,
а за Кримінальним кодексом справу взагалі мало вести СБУ.
Така непослідовність не сприяє ефективному розслідуванню.
За ці п'ять років, які були через змішування політики з питанням справедливості і правосуддя…
Це не дало добрих результатів.
Якщо наступні 5 років не буде цього фактору втручання політики
в правосуддя, то будуть дійсні результати.
Досить рано казати, чи є зацікавленість на це, чи ні, але за ці 5 років зацікавленості точно не було.
Для митця Макса Левіна знаковим будуть й інші кроки нової влади.
Його проект AFTERILOVAISK у мінінформполітики під керівництвом Юрія Стеця не підтримали.
Сказали, що фінансування будь-яких проектів, пов'язаних з Іловайськом не буде,
оскільки це історія втрат, трагедій і так далі...
Чи зміниться інформаційна політика з новим урядом, поки невідомо.
Нині висновки неоднозначні.
З одного боку, новий глава держави 29 серпня призначив Днем пам’яті захисників України,
а з іншого - родичі загиблихпереживають, щов офіційній назві немає згадки про Іловайськ,
і з часом може бути менше пам’яті про ті трагічні події.